seiga enter a world of legendary heroes
mythical locations and monstrous
creatures a world where reality itself
ripples in storms of magical power and
thousand strong legions of warriors
clash in wars with
choose a vase and a legendary Lord to
lead your campaign each is unique
bringing with them their own challenges
strengths traits and skills
total war Warhammer is a game of two
different but connected game modes the
first takes place on the turn-based
grand campaign map where you must plan
and execute strategies for survival and
conquest
the second comes into play when armies
clash on the campaign map and you have
the chance to command your troops in
breathtaking real-time battles on the
campaign map you must capture and manage
settlements or choose to burn them to
the ground engage in statecraft and
diplomacy brimming with intrigue and
tactical depth maneuver armies as you
see fit and command heroes to help
through sabotage assassination attempts
and much more besides these heroes from
the campaign map can also join you in
battle lending their special abilities
to the fight to unlock the full
potential of both your lords and heroes
on and off the battlefield level them up
send them on quests and maximize the
skills and spells at their disposal
with separate personal campaign and
battle skill trees you can really
customize your characters and even
rename them to opportunities for war are
countless whether its surrounding and
besieging your foe intercepting the
enemy underground or engaging them in
titanic battles across mythical lands
with magic colossal beasts steam spewing
war machines and a staggering array of
tactical options at your disposal
total war Warhammer offers thousands of
hours of strategy gameplay this is a
world of eternal war and fleeting glory
this is a world whose fate determination
or salvation is yours to decide
this is total war Warhammer
you